foreign
[Music]
14 pro Max
[Music]
I've been using the iPhone 14 pro Max
for a week now and I've been really
trying to think of how I can explain
this year's iPhone in one sense and I
think I finally got it down the 14 pro
Max is the flagship iPhone model that
was chosen by Apple to deliver all of
the super late features that people have
been begging for for years and let me
tell you right now Apple nailed it and
not only that but they've masterfully
refined every bit of the iPhone into
their Masterpiece with all of the
aspects of the iPhone like the design
the display the performance the software
the battery life and of course the
cameras finally being refined into what
Apple has been imagining for years so
the question I'm gonna try to answer in
this review is whether Apple's mastering
of features and this iPhone is worth
upgrading to despite speculation that
next year's iPhone 15 Pro will get USBC
among other features in my answer might
just surprise you
foreign
[Music]
time with fancy music and b-roll let's
get right down to business and talk
about the notch which people have wanted
Apple to get rid of ever since the
iPhone 10 and they finally delivered or
have they Apple's Dynamic Island took
the Internet by storm when they
surprised everyone with it at their
Apple event even convincing some people
to upgrade for that feature alone but it
seems like the sentiment has shifted a
bit once users actually started using it
some people are complaining that you can
see the individual cutouts when it's in
direct sunlight and in my honest opinion
I don't think this matters or negatively
impacts the experience at all others are
complaining that it's not as useful or
active as Apple made it look in their
marketing well duh it's marketing and of
course with regular use the dynamic
Island won't be used all the time but
even after only one week I've already
found that it makes using my iPhone more
convenient first off I love how fluid
and smooth the animation are like when
face ID authenticates and for the first
time ever I can see timers counting down
at all times the dynamic Island also
fixed the number one thing that I hated
on my iPhone the low battery
notification that used to fill up your
entire display now simply pops up in the
island not only that but I've actually
noticed myself using it for Apple music
allowing me to jump straight into the
music app by tapping the island instead
of having to go through my app switcher
to find it and of course you can tap and
hold to bring up the pop-up however I
wish Apple switched the controls to this
one tap brings up the pop-up and a
second tab opens the app no more tap and
hold please but what a lot of people are
misunderstanding about the island is
that it's a brand new feature and it's
gonna take a few months before we really
start seeing it become incredibly useful
as more third-party developers add
support for things like live activities
for sports games in the latest IOS 16
beta or even the cool little Tamagotchi
feature for the Reddit app Apollo so my
point of view is that Apple did
absolutely solid work on the Island's
Hardware itself finally deleting the
Notch and replacing it with something
that feels fresh fluid actually useful
and ready for developers to take on so
just give it some time but what really
impressed me was that Apple not only
redesigned the speaker Grille to be
three times thinner but they've greatly
improved the speakers All Around Just
Hear It for yourself
[Music]
not only are the speakers much louder
than before but the quality got better
in every aspect including the bass mids
and the highs where they're now more
soft and clear and even better the
dynamic range of frequencies is now
wider so you can make out different
instruments or Tunes where you couldn't
before so this is a big deal for me now
moving on I've got to cover the number
one thing that people will notice right
away and that's the always-on display
after so many years of this feature
being missing Apple has finally added it
but unfortunately a lot of people are
complaining about it being too bright so
bright that they keep thinking the
display is on when it's not and to that
my reply is that they're simply just not
used to it give it a week or two you and
it'll feel like second nature and
honestly this is the first always on
display I've ever seen that still
retains your wallpaper in the background
instead of being completely black so
it's totally unique to Apple but the
downside with that is that people are
noticing worse battery life with this on
and in my personal use I haven't really
noticed a huge drop in battery life
probably because I don't like using the
auto brightness setting which is the
only way to experience the new 2000 nits
of brightness Outdoors but in reality
Apple should probably just give us the
option to dim down the always on display
brightness to help save battery life
instead of being forced to completely
turn it off but as far as the always-on
display itself I absolutely love it
since I no longer forget about
notifications that popped up for a
couple of seconds before the display
shuts off like what happened previously
now they are always there so I can't
miss them the only problem with it right
now is that you have to tap on the
display once before you can tap into a
notification I really just wish Apple
would make it so you could tap the
notification straight from the always on
display and it'll authenticate with base
ID open it up and go straight into that
app so I hope Apple changes that but on
the plus side Apple has made unlocking
your iPhone more convenient than ever
before by adding swipe to wake so all
you have to do is swipe out from the
bottom to instantly authenticate with
face ID and unlock the phone which is a
major game changer for ease of use now
moving on to the performance not that
much has changed in terms of the raw
power of the a16 bionic chip so nobody
should be upgrading for that but there
are some major upgrade worthy changes
this year like the new Snapdragon x65
modem which is not only quite a bit
faster than the previous x60 but it also
runs cooler which leads to less heat
which is the other major change for the
last couple of years display dimming has
been a very annoying issue on the pro
iPhones and this year Apple has finally
improved the cooling performance by
adding this new thermal tape which helps
spread some of the heat away from the
chip faster than before which you can
visually see in this thermal camera
comparison and because of that display
dimming has been significantly improved
this year now it's not completely gone
like when stress testing the graphics
but it's much better than it was before
staying at a consistently higher
brightness level when dimmed down so
it's not instantly noticeable and
annoying like before now before I show
you how this impacts gaming performance
if you're a Mac User who does any type
of work with documents spreadsheets or
slideshows on your Mac software keep is
giving our viewers 20 off on genuine
Microsoft software like a one-time
purchase of Microsoft Office for Mac
which includes word excel and PowerPoint
now there are so many fishy websites out
there that could scam you but software
keep is a Microsoft certified partner
who sells only 100 genuine Microsoft
software so you don't have to worry
which resulted in software keep earning
over a hundred thousand five star
reviews they also have great prices on
other software including the most
popular antivirus software out there and
their customer service is phenomenal
with 24 7 365 customer support where
you'll talk to a real person instead of
a robot so if you have any questions
they'll be glad to help so buy Microsoft
Office for Mac or anything else you need
today and save 20 off they're already
great prices by using the link in the
description and the coupon code Max Tech
20. now getting back into gaming I was
even able to play Call of Duty mobile at
100 brightness with no dimming
whatsoever which was honestly shocking
since the iPhone 13 Pro Max would dim
down in less than a minute in this
scenario so this change makes the Iphone
experience so much better and now before
I get into some of the downsides because
yes there are downsides we've got to
talk about the cameras now on the
surface it seems like not that much has
changed with the main camera even though
it's the biggest jump in megapixels and
sensor size we've ever had in an iPhone
and that's because for some reason the
new 48 megapixel camera still defaults
to shooting 12 megapixel photos by
combining or bidding 4 pixels into one
and because of that you can't really see
a big difference between the 14 pro and
13 Pro's main cameras at least in the
daytime now in the night time you can
clearly see that the 14 pro is better
because the larger sensor helps it
gather more light and you can easily say
the same thing for all of the other
cameras the ultra wide the telephoto the
selfie camera all of them have been
improved in terms of low light and night
mode photos which by itself could
convince some people to upgrade and by
the way each of those other cameras have
no noticeable improvements in the
daytime as well especially the ultra
wide and selfie cameras which now look
very sharp and because of those changes
the 14 pro has now leapfrogged over the
Samsung Galaxy s22 Ultra and z-fold 4 in
terms of camera quality like we showed
you in our unbiased camera comparison
whereas the 13 Pro got killed by the two
just last month and part of the reason
why the 14 pro is now so good is of
course the new 48 megapixel Pro Rock
camera mode which not only shoots at
full 48 megapixel resolution but also
with 16 bit colors and Apple's Auto
processing which is great now while some
people have shown absolutely
mind-blowing 48 megapixel Pro raw edits
online we kept things simple by
comparing a couple of photos like this
one which clearly shows the iPhone's 48
megapixel sensor beating out Samsung's
50 and 108 megapixel sensors on their
more expensive Flagship phones and
comparing it to the 13 Pro Max there was
a massive difference with the new level
of detail being easily noticeable even
on a smartphone display and some people
got creative online showing off some
absolutely stunning photos including
this one on the macramers forums showing
off the Milky Way with a user being
blown away by the maximum ISO of 12
768 saying that these iPhone photos
finally look like a DSLR image however
there are a couple of problems first of
all apple is forcing you to shoot in Pro
raw in order to take 48 megapixel photos
and those photos take a lot of storage
on average between 50 and 75 megabytes
and unfortunately Apple doesn't allow
you to shoot 48 megapixel photos using
more compressed formats like heic or
jpeg you can't even convert them on your
iPhone itself so it's really unfortunate
that Apple did this and making things
worse the 14 pro still has the same
lightning Port as before which means
that it still only supports USB 2.0
transfer speeds but since I prefer using
airdrop for transferring photos I
decided to test out how long it'll take
to airdrop 20 Pro Raw photos to my Mac
and with airdrop it took 36 seconds from
start to finish which honestly isn't
that bad and wouldn't ruin my day even
if it was a hundred of these Pro Raw
photos taking three minutes to transfer
I'd rather do that than grab a cable
anyway the bigger problem is when you
want to back up your entire iPhone to a
Mac and it takes hours and hours on end
that's where lightning 2.0 is terrible
and USBC would have solved this
instantly so hopefully Apple gives that
to us next year or maybe even
Thunderbolt but as far as the 48
megapixel sensor it's really unfortunate
that we're forced to use prores and even
worse there's no 8K video recording
which would be totally doable on this
sensor but Apple sadly chose to leave it
out this year for whatever reason but
either way Apple still easily defeats
every other smartphone brand in terms of
video recording like the new action mode
that's not only more smooth and sharper
than Samsung's steady cam but it also
crops in way less making it far superior
as well as Apple's cinematic mode that
now supports 4K resolution making it
absolutely destroy the other two Samsung
flat ships so personally I finally think
that I'm going to start using cinematic
mode for regular use whenever I have a
subject to record so for the cameras I'm
pleasantly surprised with all aspects
except for Apple's portrait cutouts that
still have some issues and the dynamic
range not being as great as some of the
competitors especially for the ultra
wide camera now with all that said I've
got to add in some of the downsides
Apple forced our hand in terms of
removing this SIM card slot just so they
could move the industry forward which is
cool and all but it makes it more
difficult for us buyers to travel on top
of that we still don't have Wi-Fi 6E on
the 14 pro which is kind of ridiculous
in 2022 and to think that I was about to
splurge on a Wi-Fi 6E router at home
because of the leaks and rumors and I'm
also a bit disappointed that the display
bezels didn't really get that much
thinner and of course it really ticks me
off that Apple didn't add 8K video
recording When the 48 megapixel sensor
easily supports it but other than that I
think the iPhone camera system is the
most refined it's ever been as well as
their display quality which has
seemingly hit Peak refinement along with
the Best in Class always on display mode
the fastest chip available in any
smartphone with minimal dimming this
time the most refined Notch that's
actually useful and speaker equality
that is so good I'm shocked that it's
coming from a smartphone so that makes
this the most refined iPhone ever the
only question is should you actually
upgrade to it or wait just one more year
for the 15 Pro which will likely get
USBC and a five times zoom camera well
to be completely honest if you're
upgrading from an iPhone 11 Pro or older
you're gonna experience a massive
difference from the display quality and
the cameras to the top tier Max save
charging system and cellular performance
and even if you're upgrading from the 12
Pro I'd argue that there are still some
big improvements you'll notice
particularly in terms of fixing the
display dimming issues the cameras and
the battery life and yes I know that
USBC is going to be a nice upgrade but
I've realized that I almost exclusively
charge using macsafe and my MacBook Pro
at home now uses Max safe as well so I
wouldn't be able to use one USBC cable
to charge both of them anyway so in my
case USBC won't really change that much
and yes I'm excited for the five times
telephoto camera which is currently in
the rumor cycle but I rarely take far
range telephoto Zoom photos anyway so I
could live without it and if you can
agree with me on that and you have an
older iPhone then I'd say that this year
is finally the perfect year to upgrade
because the new Dynamic Island and the
always on display are fresh differences
you'll experience daily as well as the
fact that I'm a little bit biased
towards the new space black color which
I've been asking for for years now but
with that said hopefully you enjoyed
this one week review of the 14 pro Max
and if you did go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe for more
content like this and if you're unsure
about which iPhone 14 model to buy check
out our buyer's guide right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
foreign